How did it feel?
I mean, when you got your results.
I think more than anything,
it felt kind of like relief.
Fingernails is about a world
pretty similar to ours,
other than the fact that there's
a new test that's been invented.
The device can tell you how compatible
you are with a partner.
And so this Love Institute is born.
I created the program
to make the bond of love stronger.
We're not here
to try to teach people to fall in love.
That would be insane.
We're here to try to bring them
closer together.
Love is the most elusive thing.
We are all looking for love
and find something real.
Anna is in a 100% tested relationship
with Ryan.
Everything on
the surface is great, but there's just
a little bit of doubt within Anna
think she secretly comes to work
in the institute because she wants to try
and fight for something that she feels
is lacking within her relationship.
Hi. Hi.
I’m Amir.
I'm Anna.
Amir is working at the Love Institute
to try and understand what love is.
Since the test has been invented,
it's been shown
that actually,
most people are not in love.
We've forgotten what it really is
to be focused on your partner.
The film is dealing with such
massive themes
in a really thoughtful and specific way.
Do you still have strong feelings for him?
You're not just dealing
with these test results.
You're dealing with love
and the idea of love.
We all strive for 100% tested
love relationships,
but the reality of it is that it's much
messier than that.